we're told each big square below
represents one whole express the shaded
area as both a mixed number and a
decimal so pause this video and see if
you can do that what would this be as a
mixed number and then what would it be
as a decimal all right now let's do it
together so let's first start with the
mixed number so we see that we have one
hole here the whole thing is filled out
so this is going to be one hole and then
over here we have part of this second
hole filled out and it looks like we are
dividing this hole into 10 equal
sections and then two of those are
filled out so as a mixed number we have
one and then you have two of the tenths
filled out so this is going to be one
and two tenths and we're done you can
see here this is split into tenths and
we filled in two of them now what about
as a decimal well we could just express
one into tenths as a decimal we could
say hey that's going to be one and then
we get to the tenths place and then how
many tenths do we have we have two of
them so that's going to be one point two
let's do another example so here this is
a little bit more involved they say once
again each big square below represents
one hole and once again they want us to
express the shaded areas both a fraction
and a decimal so pause this video and
have a go at this all right so let's
start with a fraction again so we have
one hole two holes and then partially
shaded in this third hole so if I'm
gonna express this as a fraction really
is going to be a mixed number I would
say that this over here this is two
wholes now this third hole is only
partially filled in and we can see that
it has been divided into hundredths
you can see it's a 10 by 10 grid so each
of these squares represent one hundredth
of a hole and how many of these
hundredths are filled in well you let's
say you have 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 and
then you have 70
one two three four we can see that
seventy-four of the hundredths are
filled in so as a mixed number this
whole thing would represent two and
seventy four hundredths now if we want
to write it as a decimal we would have
two holes and then we could go to the
tenths place you could just write two
and seventy four hundreds like that if
you're pretty familiar with it you could
also think about it in terms of how many
tenths and how many hundredths do you
have we have one two three four five six
seven tenths and then we have four more
hundredths beyond that you could think
of it as seventy four hundredths or
seven tenths and four hundreds but
either way we are done